Jesus practiced what he
preached Jesus Is God who became man the
perfect man who perfectly practiced what
he preached look at what Jesus did as an
example for us Ephesians 3:8 to me
though I am the very least of all the
saints this favor this Grace was given
to preach what watch here kitty everyone
else The unsearchable Riches of Christ
I'm here to Proclaim to you that our
lord Jesus is infinitely Rich his riches
you
cannot Plum the depth of his riches and
you can never deplete his riches you
have a god who's infinitely rich and
loves you and wants you to share in his
riches here it is you see it Ephesians
38 but look what Jesus did for you may
we do what our Lord did do for our Lord
what our Lord did for us here it is
second Corin
88:9 2 Corinthians
88:9 here it is watch here
Tyler Jesus practiced what he preached 2
Corinthians 8 ver9 please Holy Spirit
give us perfect attentiveness and
convict me to practice what I preach Set
Me Free from my fear I'm not having
enough 2 Corinthians 8 ver9 watch sagon
watch for you know you who are born of
the spirit the grace the favor our Lord
Jesus Christ that though he was rich for
your sake he became poor Park on that
message Holy Spirit take this verse
plant it in our souls our Spirits in our
hearts on our tongues and our minds to
reflect not forget and to act upon the
example of Our Lord why he became poor
so that by his poverty he may make you
rich the one who's infinitely Rich
practice what he preached he gave up the
riches of Heaven the glory the status of
being on the throne humbled himself to
take on flesh to become a human baby
born in a poor
household practiced what he preached 2
Corinthians 8
ver9 he gave up his Heavenly Mansion
because Jesus is real this is a true
story
he was on the
throne Heavenly
Mansion Heaven whose beauty is beyond
description visibly on the throne before
he became flesh from the Virgin having
the Angels worship him seeing him in his
glory and
voluntarily gave up the
throne appeared on Earth by becoming
flesh being born of the Holy virgin to a
poor carpenter
practice what he preached because he had
to set aside The Riches of Heaven in
order to pay your debt to now Elevate
you and forgive you and restore you so
now he could make you rich and a coair
in his riches that's what he
did and you're not willing to give up a
mansion on Earth for him or a car for
him or Netflix or Hulu or Amazon for him
so you can have more money to use to
serve those in Need by your Deeds to
show them that you love Jesus more than
you love your status and because of
Jesus here you you neighbor you're
barely making it every month I'm going
to commit myself so what do you lack
$500 every month I'm going to give you
$700 to help you get on your
feet and you don't pay me back because
my reward is from the
Lord
okay did you catch what he
did guys want me can I take a moment to
show you how poor Jesus
became he could have chosen to be born
in a wealthy family someone who was very
affluent Rich he chose a poor comp
Carpenter do you know how poor Joseph
and Mary were can I show you the Holy
Spirit purged my motive I rech you Holy
Spirit please own my heart and purify my
motives to do it from Pure Love for
Jesus Christ not for selfish gain Save
Me From Myself and then enable me to
practice what I preach do you want me to
show you how poor our Lord
was it's so subtle in Scripture that if
you don't know the Old Testament yep
full armor you got it you won't make the
connection exactly leonitis you got it
now Focus now let me show you when a
woman gave birth to a child
she would have to go to the temple offer
the sacrifice for her purification why
because after you give birth postpartum
right there's excessive flow of blood
right so you wait for that period to
end and then you go and offer sacrifices
for purification now watch
Leviticus chapter
12 look what it says in verse eight okay
now let me read 68 so you see what the
regular sacrifice would be if you can
afford it watch here Leviticus 1268
watch here pay
attention exactly please listen
Leviticus 1268 and when the days of rep
purifying are
completed when the blood flow stops
after pregnancy okay whether for a son
or for a daughter right she shall bring
to the priest at the door of the 10 of
meaning a lamb a year old for a burnt
offering and a young pigeon for a turtle
dove or a turtle dove for a sin offering
lamb pigeon or Dove now watch and she or
he shall offer it before the Lord the
priest will do it on her behalf and make
atonement for her then she shall be
clean from the flow of her blood now
watch this this is the law for her who
Bears a child either male or female now
watch what happens if they're poor what
do they offer they poor pay attention
please listen the heart of our God and
if she cannot afford a
lamb then she shall take two doves two
does or two young pigeons so if you're
too poor two doves or two pigeons one
for a burnt offering and the other for
sin offering and the priest shall make
atonement for her and she shall be clean
when Mary had to follow the law guess
what they offered remember if you're
poor what do you
offer okay two doves or two pigeons now
watch look how poor our Lord was Luke
2: 22 to 24 it is so subtle that here
Luke tells you how poor he
was but you got to know the Old
Testament look what Mary and Joseph
offered Luke
222 right to 24 and when the time came
for their purification according to the
law of Moses they brought him up to
Jerusalem to present him to the Lord as
it is written in the law of the Lord
every male right that opens the womb
Shall be Called holy to the Lord now
look what Mary and Joseph offered in
Jesus name focus and to offer a
sacrifice according to what is said in
law of the Lord a pair of two turtle
doubs or two pigeons that's all they
could offer do you see here Luke gives
you a hint how poor Joseph and Mary
happen to be and and this is the family
that Jesus chose to be born
in and you who name the name of Christ
want to keep hoarding on
Earth Matthew 6 19-21 and 24 write that
down Matthew 6 19-21 and 24 do not store
up Treasures on Earth so you want to
keep having mansions and rolls-royces
and
Mercedes see
that they could not even afford a lamb
or a pigeon or a turtle dove they could
only afford two turtle doubs or pigeons
the sacrifice of the
poor yep Jesus is the Lamb obviously but
he was not offered there at that
[Applause]
moment are we getting it did it sink in
before I get into the meat of the
matter okay focus what's the point here
that Mary and Joseph were poor they
could only afford the two turtes or two
pigeons not the lamb and the dove or the
lamb and the pigeon an indication how
humble the Lord is that he knew this is
the woman that will give birth to me and
this is the man that will raise me the
poorest of the poor and on top of that
the Lord would have to the Lord would
have to learn Joseph's trade of all the
people that he chose to raise him up he
chose a carpenter in the first century
who would have to then carry huge
Stones try to then carry
wood right fashion wood stones to build
homes in that first century setting back
breaking work so from the time he is
mature enough to work he'd have to get
up either cold or heat carry
Stones wood have to use Hammer whatever
they use at that time
nails cut wood and only the Lord knows
how many splinters he had how many
injuries he had right and did it humbly
without
complaining he could have made it easy
for himself he could have chose an
affluent family the one who's infinitely
Rich who owns Heaven and Earth the
entire creation belongs to Jesus Heaven
and Earth are his and he practiced what
he
preached so who are you man that think
you deserve better who are you man that
you think that you need to have more
Mansions bigger homes more expensive
cars because I want to compete with the
richest and finest and rub shoulders
with them when the king of kings and
Lord of lords is looking upon you with
disdain yep he was a stonemason that's
my point that's why you carry Stones
because that's what a carpenter was at
that
time right te
time you understand May the spirit
control me and use me to convict and I
pray I practice what I preach you
understand what I just got at before I
begin
yep exactly Byzantine isn't it amazing
Jesus chose to be born in a carpenter's
home to be the adoptive son of a
carpenter making him the carpenter the
son of the carpenter when he is the
carpenter the Craftsman who designed and
created the heavens and the Earth so in
both Natures he's the son of the
carpenter who imitates his father in his
trade so he is the carpenter the son of
the carpenter because as God he's the
carpenter who fashioned and created
heavens and earth and his father is the
fashioner of Heaven and Earth so as God
he's a carpenter the son of the
carpenter who fashioned and created the
heavens and the Earth as a tabernacle
for the godhead to dwell in and as man
he became a carpenter and the son of a
carpenter you see from both pers
perspectives because who fashion who
created heaven the Earth as a building
as a temple to dwell in father son Holy
Spirit in fact in job 38: 4-7 job 38:
4-7 it says God created the Earth as a
building as a building as a temple to
live in so Jesus as God is the Divine
Carpenter son of the Divine Carpenter
because with his father God he fashioned
designed created the heavens and the
Earth everything in them along with the
Holy Spirit then he becomes man and
chooses to be adopted by a carpenter so
now as a man he's a carpenter the son of
a
carpenter continuing to do what he did
from creation where he with his father
in the spirit fashioned the heavens and
the earth now as a man he spends his
life fashioning and building homes on
Earth
right sinking
in did it all make
sense I know there's some of you I don't
know for sure who but I know if the
spirit wanted me to speak this that
means he's trying to speak to some of
you may he speak to me and I practice
what I preach there's some of you that
this hit you because you're rich you
have a mansion like I said and you have
a Mercedes and a roll-royce I'm not
trying to make you feel guilty but you
need to be convicted why are you storing
up and wanting more when you see there
are orphans and widows struggling your
brothers and sisters struggling there
are Christian homeless shelters that
need financial support there are
Christian shelters who provide food and
a bed and clothing and you can help them
financially and then you know poor among
you that can need can use your support
and then you know there are min
Mysteries that need to be supported and
God can work through you to take your
riches and use that to build his kingdom
on Earth as you build riches in heaven
you know who you are I don't know who
you are honestly I don't I'm not lying I
don't know who's rich here but I know
there
are and I didn't plan to talk about this
so there was a reason for me to talk
about this